pensez-vous du célibat tout cela avant
tout à fait d'abord globalement dans les
années 60 mieux ne valait pas être
célibataire mais petit à petit les
choses ont bougé avant les apaiser les
sites de rencontres pour rompre le
terrible sort du célibat dans les années
60 et 70 il y avait les foires aux maris
et les foire aux célibataires et il n'y
a qu'à écouter des concurrents pour
comprendre la pression alors vous
espérez trouver un mari cette jeune
femme vient d'échapper à ce qui à
l'époque pouvait être une des pires
malédiction féminine qui soit finir
vieille fille et mourir sous la piste et
de ceux qui l'entourent enfin dans les
années 70 les choses bougent tout
doucement
cette génération est élevé en pensant
que la solitude est une tare
je pense que la solitude ça peut être
une épreuve mais c'est aussi une source
de richesse une source de richesse
d'indépendance et de liberté et même
pour les femmes comme pour les hommes
bien qu'à écouter la rue dans les années
80 je suis la fed est célibataire
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez souhaiter le
rester la bigamie
ça serait à recommencer je me marierai
pas aller coq être célibataire ce n'est
plus vraiment une honte c'est même
clairement revendiquée parfois je pense
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est un choix
d'être célibataire parce que c'est c'est
pas une de mes priorités actuelles la
priorité je la mettrais plutôt sur mon
travail et le mouvement gagne du terrain
ça vient notamment de scandinavie en
suède
ils sont un petit peu en avance sur nous
mais ça ça vient également des grandes
villes vers les campagnes l'ampleur du
phénomène elle se résume en un mot
apparu dans les années 2000
célibat temps célibattante ils ont fait
de la vie en solo un art pour des
raisons de carrière ou de liberté et
aujourd'hui on en est où
et bien selon un sondage opinionway
d'octobre 2010 8 63% des célibataires
sont satisfaits d'être célibataire
[Musique]